foreign
[Music]
Google Cloud's VPC service controls or
vpcsc is a security product that allows
you to control access to Google cloud
services with vpcsc you can create
service parameters that Define which
Google cloud services can be accessed
and you can control how those services
are accessed
vpcsc lets you create an extra layer of
security defense for Google cloud
services and resources it complements
IAM which provides granular
identity-based Access Control
vpcsc can help you further improve
security reduce risk of data
exfiltration and address compliance
requirements
by simply creating a service perimeter
around your projects and VPC Networks
you prevent access to Google cloud
services from outside the perimeter you
also restrict access from inside the
service perimeter to Services outside
the perimeter
however sometimes there may be business
needs for connections to cross perimeter
boundaries Ingress and egress rules will
allow access across perimeter boundaries
allowing services in the perimeter to be
accessed from outside the perimeter and
allowing resources within the perimeter
to connect to services outside of it
one important security aspect that vpcsc
helps with is reducing risks of data
exfiltration so how do these service
controls help
vbcsc by default prevents any
connectivity from outside the perimeter
thus immediately reducing the risk of
data exposure or exfiltration
any connectivity attempts from threat
actors outside the perimeter is
immediately blocked
users inside the perimeter cannot copy
data to Google services outside the
perimeter as well
by restricting access to only the people
and services that need access to your
customer data you make sure only those
with a business need even have a chance
of seeing that data by limiting the data
that can go between your perimeter and
external Services you reduce the
potential to exfiltrate data and with
auditable logs you have the ability to
find where data is going
the SC also helps address compliance
requirements with industry and
government regulations
by providing a way to control access to
Google cloud services you are set up to
successfully follow regulations around
who and what resources can access your
data
vpcsc also leverages geographic
information to restrict which
geographies can connect to data thus
supporting data residency goals
audit logs show that you are taking
steps to follow regulations and protect
your data
this allows you to generate reports to
show how you are using Google cloud
services and that you are addressing the
compliance requirements if you need a
way to add security perimeters mitigate
data exfiltration and help address your
compliance regulation requirements
VPC service controls provide a strong
security defense layer for your Cloud
environment learn more about vpcsc by
following the link on screen and in the
description
thanks for watching and keeping your
data safe with Google Cloud
[Music]